Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David, Pee Wee, the San Antonio troll is back.
If anybody was worried that he wasn't doing
well or whatever the case may be, he's fine.
He's calling back.
The San Antonio troll is known for criticizing
me for things I haven't said.
Let's take a listen back.
Speaker 5: We have had the same voicemail
message for like ten years now, time that
day.
Anyway, I am either I 100 percent for backing.
Now, that includes the illegal David Pakman.
It got me the gun.
That's right.
And when you do something medevacing in your
own holier than thou liberalists, OK, you
do not foresee the two way street that is.
I hope now everybody is like, yeah, we mandate
vaccines are where you come from, let's do
it.
That means no more illegal spackman lot votes
for Democrats.
Unless you remember,
Speaker 1: undocumented immigrants don't vote
because they're not citizens.
There's really no I mean, what, what would
it mean for undocumented immigrants to vote?
Each one would need to know of some registered
voter.
Go to the polling place and say, hey, I'm
John Smith, and then the next person says,
Hey, I'm Suzy, whatever, and you'd have to
hope you showed up before the real voter.
It's a crazy way to try to steal an election.
It just wouldn't work.
There's no evidence it's even been tried.
Speaker 5: Honestly, if that were the case,
if Democrats were consistent on this issue,
I would probably vote.
Democrats can say, because now you have Democrats
like yourself and even Democrat politicians
say, oh, we could we could take in tens of
billions from a stop in Central America, just
bring over and unvaccinated.
But why do we care about this?
No, no, no.
Let's do the vaccine mandate.
And I me, it's this crazy to protect America
myself in their faith.
And good luck getting yourself out of that
one.
Anyway, I think in South America,
Speaker 1: Ed, does anybody have even the
slightest idea what that caller is talking
about?
It seems to be a combination of confusion
and reacting things that somebody else must
have said.
It's very common that this guy calls in and
attacks me for things I haven't said on today's
Bonas show.
Texas has now announced an audit of 20-20
votes in four counties.
What's the point?
Trump won Texas.
We'll talk about it on the bonus show.
Number two, a federal judge has blocked a
vaccine mandate for New York City teachers.
Why and what happens now?
And number three on the bonus show, what about
3D printing your own vaccine at home?
And instead of being a shot into the body,
as Trump says, it's a patch.
Very interesting new technology that apparently
offers an opportunity for even more effective
immunization and antibody response.
All of those stories and more are on today's
bonus show.
Get instant access by signing up at Join Pakman
dot com coupon code, dystopian rally.
All one word.
Unidentified: All lowercase, dystopian.